[Music]
Stephen twitch boss has died he was 40
years old boss's wife Allison holker
confirmed the news in a statement
writing in part that he lit up every
room he stepped into I have the sweetest
husband in the entire world quote he
valued family friends and Community
Above All Else and leading with love and
light was everything to him
holker also reflects on her husband's
Legacy adding quote he was the backbone
of our family the best husband and
father and an inspiration to his fans
[Applause]
boss and Hulk are shared two children
together six-year-old son Maddox and
three-year-old daughter ziya as well as
hulker's 14 year old daughter Wesley
from a previous relationship we love the
Full House and also just like family man
and my favorite they're my favorite
people polker concluded her statement
with one final message to her husband
Stephen we love you we miss you and I
will always Save the Last Dance For You
I feel like we connect a lot through
dance it just makes every single day so
fun
boss died on Tuesday according to TMZ
Folker entered a Los Angeles police
station and reported that her husband
had left home without his car shortly
after LAPD reportedly responded to
gunshots at a Los Angeles hotel where
boss was found dead from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound
boss first rose to Fame in 2008 as the
runner-up on So You Think You Can Dance
[Music]
I tried out I told myself if I did if I
didn't make the show my next move would
be to the uh the office of the Navy to
enlist
um so I would literally be doing
something completely different had it
not worked out so it's just it is
blessed he later served as the house DJ
on The Ellen Degeneres Show from 2014
until the series ended earlier this year
becoming an executive producer on the
show in the process filming the last
episode of Ellen it was really the the
end of an era and and also it was so
emotional and so inspiring I'm just so
grateful boss also appeared on the big
screen alongside Channing Tatum in Magic
Mike XXL and was famous for spreading
Joy on tick tock foreign
[Music]
something that we do
um organically anyway Boston Hulker tied
the knot in 2013. the two recently
celebrated their ninth wedding
anniversary how do you all still
keep that spark
spark million other things to do
and truth it's I mean it's a mixture of
things but even if it's 10 minutes just
like just kind of to take together just
to sit and just be with each other it's
important for us to connect and just
like kind of like let go of everything
else is happening in the world
on Saturday the dancer shared a series
of throwback picks from their big day
wishing his wife a happy anniversary in
the caption we do a lot together we do
we actually do like each other we kind
of look at life as being our playground
we like to try new things we like to
have fun and we want to enjoy the
experiences that we're having we want to
have each other there to experience it
together it's all about playing with the
ones that you love still liking them and
loving them at the same time
thank you